I don't work with people who count on me to put up 50 point how wrong were people who put up video there I'm gonna
Pick that one up can we murder you you don't deserve to be surrounded by greatness unless you are great yourself
That's the problem the intensity that you have it has to be in everything you do you have to be an intense person
Rise and shine it's in spresso time what's up believe nation it's Evan I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily success
routine so let's start your day off right together grab your coffee and sip on today's message be
intentional
Over to you Eric Thomas
Everything is intentional come on
intentional you got to be
intentional and deliberate and everybody that's running what you got to be intentional delivered see this this what I don't do I don't hang with
people who can only get up when they got something to motivate them
that's not something I wanna hang out with I wanna hang out what to do in Boston you can kill them and
Detroit you can kill them in
Toronto you can bring the noise
Are you here when?
I'm telling you I'm gonna hang with somebody I don't care what the circumstances
I don't care what the situation you putting on your back and you like let's go
I don't run with people who count
On me to put up 50 point I run with people put up Vicki out
I put up Vicki that put up and we murder you look Mike that's why I was Big Mike
Look at some highlights y'all
magic was the man Larry Bird with man
Doubront come on Black Mamba the man go back and look at some highlights y'all y'all
go back and look at the highlights - MJ go look at the highlights oh look at that
intensity my man head go look at the highlights watch Jordan
y66 he's trying to hear this boom and looked at you like boom
He was sure that he was the only one that make a check he started that he's making J an assassination
Just to hit only one jump only one in history who would dunk on you it didn't stop you
The only one offensive
Massacre and defensive assassination I'll take it from you I'll rip it for you and you'll watch me go down boom
don't make your crowd shut up I'll take them off the game where you'll hear me got a doll
You don't deserve to be surrounded by greatness unless you are great yourself
That's the problem you want to have Michael Jordan on your team but Michael Jordan doesn't want to play with you
because you don't bring enough to the table
Yet you need to become the Michael Jordan of something and when you do that other
Jordans will want to play ball with you but until that happens you'll stay stuck
complaining that the people around you suck it took me three years of trying to get Tony Robbins on my show
For him to come on and us to do an interview which we did earlier this year Tony welcome aboard man
examine good to be with you
now actually I had one lined up with him two years ago after year of trying I had him signed up to come on and
Do an interview and then last minute they, cancelled and say hey we want to do this
We want to have him back on let's make it work
two more years of trying until that actually happened to get him on my channel and the reality is I
wasn't good enough yet I
wasn't seen as a Jordan yet I
wasn't bringing enough to the table yet compared to what
Tony Robbins was bringing I needed to continue to up my game I needed to continue to get better
I needed to continue to improve my reputation I need to continue to improve my skills I need to continue to build
my audience and my platform so that I was seen as a Jordan and not just being seen as a Jordan by being a
Jordan and
three years of hard work
Later I got Tony Robbins to come on my channel and so the same thing applies in your life maybe you want to have Tony
Robbins in your life maybe you want to interview somebody else or hanging around different level of people
but they don't want to hang with you yet
They don't think you're good enough yet and that's, okay don't complain don't quit don't give up don't feel like you suck
Don't hang in the towel you know don't throw it in don't say I said I'm done I'm just gonna stay where I am
It's just a challenge it's a challenge to get better it's a challenge to rise above your circumstances it's a challenge to continue to improve
To get better to hone your craft to bring more, value to
build your skill up to be Michael Jordan level at what you're doing
So here's a three step process to bring more Michael Jordan level people into your life
Step number one is find the gap you got to figure out what is it that you can bring to the table
that's different that brings value so look at me in 20 Robbins Tony's been doing this
for a long long long long long time why does he care about me well because I built up enough of a youtube audience because
I have enough traction now because I have X number of subscribers on my channel
that's the gap that's how I closed it so this things that you could do
That become valuable to other people that they're not good at tony is not
pumping out tons of content in his YouTube channel Tony wants to get his message spread to a bigger audience especially entrepreneurs
that's what I could provide so you have to figure out what's the gap what value can you bring to these people it's not about
Going to Tony and saying hey I want to intern for you on a work for you for free for a year and then maybe
You'll hire me that doesn't work that's not a fair value exchange you giving your time for free
Even for free you don't have to pay me anything right that is not valuable enough to 20 Robbins
you're actually disrespecting his time because you're whatever wage you be earning is not enough his time was worth more than that and
So you think you're bringing in same value but you're not
you have to find the gap you have to figure out how can you bring this person in
Same value that they care about you and you're on their radar and they want to hang with you find the gap
Step number two is just practice you have to get better at your thing if you're committed to this you want to be Michael Jordan
Or something you got to practice
Jordan was the first one in the last one that go right he put in the most work you have to put in the work
I'm
making three videos a day on my youtube channel I'm putting in the work hopefully I get better at it
as I keep putting in more work you won't get good if you don't practice enough and so you found the gap great maybe there's
An opportunity to help Tony Robbins or somebody with their Instagram strategy
The older generation they don't understand Instagram it's an opportunity for you to go and win great
there's a lot of people who are doing Instagram you
To get good at it you need to be the Michael Jordan of Instagram used to be the Michael Jordan of Facebook Ads you got
to be the Michael Jordan of something
To bring that value and you can get there quickly but you have to practice you got to do the work
practice every single day to actually develop the skills
So that you can be recognized as being one of the best and step number three is look at timing windows
People are vulnerable at certain times so with Tony why he eventually came on the show was he had his new book
unshakeable that was going from hardcover to softcover and he wanted to do some promotion for it great I'm ready come on board
Right so paying attention to the timing window before that Tony wasn't interested he was doing his other stuff he didn't need extra promotion when
somebody is launching something when - trying to get more exposure for something
that's when they're gonna want to talk to you that's when they're more vulnerable that's when they need the most help and so follow people
Instagram follow them on Twitter follow them on their social channels and wait for them to be in promotion mode wait for them to launch
something new and if they're launching something new and they need all the help they can get
and you're they're offering it help with something because you are Michael Jordan add that thing
it's an easy yes now
I've got a really special bonus clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but before that
Question of the day I want to know what's the gap that you're gonna fill let me know put in the comments below
So we're both workout guys we like to go to that would be like that we like to go to the gym all right
How many times have you seen people in the gym they spend more time on their playlist
taking pictures doing stuff
Aesthetic getting their work instead of getting their workout done so true it's just like you know and here's the thing all right
You're a very intense person I can tell okay. I'm a very intensive worsen your eye
we value
our time yes okay how do you get results in the gym it isn't about
spending two to three hours working people say I spent three hours
You didn't spend three out you met by time you pulled into the parking lot that buy time change
got some breakfast
Put your workout clothes on talk to eight people it did all that stuff you were there for you were there for three hours you
Did you did you that you did your three hours
No intensity yeah all right all right people talk about hey
Hey you know you post a couple workout things you see any your buff guy or you're next you're in great shape?
all right people said
And I want to look like I want to look like you all right
They don't see what it takes to look like you not only in the gym
outside of the gym the
Intensity that's there you're in the gym and I'm assuming you workout with music you had some headphones on you got to get a certain
Amount of stuff done in a certain amount of time or you're in this intensive somebody comes up to you yeah
And you don't want to be rude to them see you now you take your headphones off they ask you a question they want to?
Take a picture with you oh I recognize you from so and so on all right and then then their questions how do I get
to look like well the one way you get to look like me is leave me that Pilato best
and start hitting the side hitting the weight start start lifting yeah
it's
the intensity that you have it has to be in everything you do you have to be an intense
Person in your workouts the way you did the way you eat?
okay
that's that's intensity how do how do you fuel up your metabolism
rate so you burn in these calories so you can get that definition that's intent that's an intensity how do you get to be
Successful you know if the old man
He he or she he's so intense no you know what he and she
that's how you're supposed to be you're at a different level right and that's why I said
Anthony is so it's so important it's what really separates those individuals and you can't get into that zone and you can't get
arms and
Abs like Edie or you can't do it unless you have that intensely and you're willing to block out the distractions
We have so much access now to information you know it's literally at our fingertips
you know everything okay why are more individuals doing less because they're easily distracted
If you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that sums you up or that would be like a little beacon
if you want more Eric Thomas check out the top 50 rules video I made on him the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to believe and I'll see you there in
Life when you roll the dice worst
case scenario you're gonna land on average so don't be average because if you don't try you will get to happen